the force is strong in my family
my father hasn't
I have it
my sister hasn't
you have that power too
Chewie we're home
hey youtubers is Charlie so new Star
Wars Episode 7 trailer the cast was at
celebration so there's gonna be a
breakdown of the new footage they posted
and some of the things they said really
the big takeaway here is that the
original cast is in the trailer we don't
really see their faces with the
exception of Han Solo and Chewbacca but
this is Luke Skywalker putting his metal
hand on r2 there's been a lot of rumors
about what's going on with Luke
Skywalker in the movie but because his
voice sounds fairly normal in the
trailer I'm not expecting any vast left
turns for the character there are so
many elements from the original trilogy
in here though it's so much fun
like Vader's melted helmet though
Millennium Falcon we learned a little
bit about this desert planet is actually
it's actually not Tatooine it's called
jakku no idea how that's spelled right
now I think it's J akku but it's the
same desert planet that we see in the
last trailer where were the new cast
meets remember john boyega's plank finn
he's a stormtrooper as far as we know
they were fairly non-committal when they
were asked about that did celebration
they're like can you confirm that he
really is a stormtrooper and he's not
just masquerading as one and they
wouldn't say anything so he could be on
some sort of infiltration mission he
could be like a rebel masquerading as a
stormtrooper this is actually what the
full stormtrooper gear looks like it's
fairly close to the original trilogy
were just with a slightly modified
helmet this is Ray I think that's her
hand that's accepting the lightsaber in
the trailer there's a lot of theories
that she might be Princess Leia's secret
daughter like Han and Leia's daughter I
don't know if that's true or not because
he says the forces in my sister when
she's accepting the lightsaber I think
there's some sort of family connection
between them they also made a big deal
about all the practical shots they did
instead of you know versus CG there will
be a lot of CG in the movie but if you
look in the backgrounds you can see all
these big sets that they built they look
really beautiful really beautiful and
dirty like they should there's something
so awesome and steampunky about the
classic Star Wars universe and obviously
they're shooting on film too they're not
shooting it on digital tape JJ Abrams
called this as much a Western like a
John Ford Western as he did a sci-fi
picture so I just think that's really
awesome cuz I'm a big fan of John Ford
obviously the Empire is still a very big
deal in this movie just forget about the
expanded universe New Republic stuff
that does not exist power of [ __ ] a
vacuum so even though you know a bunch
of people died in the Battle of Endor
other people inside the Empire rushed in
to fill that leadership vacuum so
they're still very evil people leading
the Empire right
now and if you've been watching Star
Wars rebels the inquisitors are actually
gonna be a big thing they tried to set
that up in rebels here's a better shot
of poe dameron in his x-wing formation
that we had in the last trailer there's
a lot of theories that his character is
gonna be involved in the x-wing spin-off
movie here's a better shot of that cross
guard lightsaber in action and
everyone's still debating on whether or
not that's effective here we can see
this [ __ ] hitting the fan on jakku
whatever's going on between ren and finn
he's not wearing stormtrooper gear
anymore so he could be a rebel that was
just masquerading as a stormtrooper
temporarily and we see bb-8 in the
background here rolling around that's
actually practical it's not CG like they
built a robot that rolls around on set I
love that her outfit is a nice mirror
for Luke Skywalker's in Episode four
Kathleen Kennedy made a big deal about
talking about how like new women new
women of power are gonna come into the
Star Wars universe via these movies
Rey's just one example that here's a
really good shot of kylo Ren I think
he's gonna be the main antagonist like
the Darth Vader type character of
Episode seven there are a lot of rumors
that this could be add-on drivers
character but there isn't any
confirmation on that and he wasn't at
Star Wars Celebration new stormtroopers
with the new Imperial banner in the
background these are the new updated TIE
fighters obviously they've updated all
the ships because remember this is in
the future so they made slight
modifications probably improve things a
little bit
here's another awesome scene on a
practical set look how big this is none
of this is CG with the exception of the
blaster fire this looks like the new
Star Destroyer design I don't think I
don't think it's a Super Star Destroyer
it doesn't look quite big enough
here's one of the new chrome troopers
they haven't fully explained what their
role is in the Empire we could probably
guess that they're just spec ops bb-8 on
the Falcon this actually looks like it
appears earlier in the film like before
that big explosion when they're running
away it seems like based on this shot
that Han Solo and Chewbacca rescued them
in the Falcon then flying into the Down
Star Destroyer is also a nice twist on
flying into the Death Star slightly
modified tie pilot design all practical
set so we finally see Han Solo on screen
with Chewbacca he's actually like the
first original cast members face that
we've seen on screen first original cast
member that's not a droid when he says
we're home Chewie he could be talking
about a lot of things he could be
speaking in a metaphor we're fighting
the Empire again or they could be on a
planet Han Solo's from Corellia we don't
know if they're gonna visit that place
in the movie I don't think that he's
talking about
Corelli though something really telling
I think is the fact that none of these
original cast members appear together
with the exception of Han and Chewie Han
and Chewie are often one part of the
galaxy doing their own thing
Princess Leia is off on her own doing
her own thing and then Luke Skywalker's
getting his Ben Kenobi on hiding out
somewhere obviously the new cast like
the new main cast members will be coming
together in this film I'll be interested
to see how long it takes for the
original cast members to meet up or if
they even do Episode seven is really
like a transitional film like they'll be
transitioning the story to this new cast
of characters so as we move forward in
the trilogy you'll see the original cast
less and less in the new cast more and
more but overall awesome new trailer
really awesome seeing Han Solo for the
first time
Harrison Ford wasn't at Star Wars
Celebration because he's still
recovering from his plane crash but it
was really fun seeing Carrie Fisher and
Mark Hamill cry on stage so I might do
some more Star Wars videos this weekend
be sure to subscribe to get them I got
some daredevil that I'm working on
trying to get through everything before
Game of Thrones again on Sunday
so lots awesome stuff also be I'll be
tweeting about celebrational through the
weekend so if you want to follow me on
Twitter and Facebook there are links for
that in the description I know it's been
a little while since they posted a
trailer so you guys can actually click
here for the last one to watch that
again and you can click here to catch up
on all my Marvel Avengers videos thank
you so much watching there's gonna be so
much fun everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you